- [Woman] In East London,
there is a building.
It's known as the Cathedral on the Marsh,
but this is no house of worship.
It's a monument to London's sewers.
(inspiring music)
Opened in 1865, the
Crossness Pumping Station
was one of the first of
its kind in the world.
Designed in the Romanesque
style, the Victorian masterpiece
was built to tackle London's
struggles with raw sewage
and cholera outbreaks, which
killed up to 20,000 people
every year.
The plant is a testament to
beauty in both form and function
Almost every inch is adorned
with immaculate ironwork.
Long pillars support the top floor
where four steam-powered
beam engines rest,
weighing 47 tons each.
The station was part of a system devised
to collect sewage water and
discard it in the eastern part
of the city away from the center.
Despite there being other
regulations to reduce sewage
at the time, the station
has been praised for pushing
London into a healthier,
less smelly future.
As the English capital
has moved to new solutions
to keep its water clean and
flowing, this sewage cathedral
is maintained as a
museum, showing that even
the dirtiest of jobs can inspire beauty.
(inspiring music)
(piano note rings)